tout un revirement de situation hier
alors que la cour d'appel de paris a
ordonné la reprise des soins pour
vincent lambert on voyait à l'instant
les célébrations d'hier soir de la part
de ses avocats célébration d'ailleurs
qui a été bien sûr critiquer lorsqu'ils
ont appris que leur requête était
finalement accepté l'homme plongée dans
un état végétatif suite à un accident de
voiture en 2008 est devenu malgré lui le
symbole de l'opposition entre le droit à
la vie le droit allemand dans la dignité
pour aborder cette question sur le plan
éthique nous avons avec nous en studio
la professeure de l'université de
montréal
emmanuel marceau de l'école de santé
publique département de médecine sociale
et préventive
merci d'être avec nous madame marceau
qui joue si vous avez une gestion de
l'information en droit donc ça se
complètent bien les bus passent et
toujours un peu des zones prises parfois
revirement de situation en france
notamment parce qu'on a bien entendu
l'avocat dire désormais sera traitée
comme une personne handicapée alors
question le débrancher tout simplement
probablement que ce serait là une mort
naturelle mais là on est rendu au terme
de sa vie ou pas mais en fait de ce
qu'il dément ce cd question le qui
soulève beaucoup de questions et
beaucoup d'émotion les sujets très
sensibles et je pense qu'aussi chaque
cas de patient est différent l'on n'a
pas l'information médicale sur
l'espérance de vie la condition le
détail et de monsieur lambert
mais c'est sûr qu'on peut se poser est
quel son kelly son espérance de vie
quels sont les traitements quels sont
les soins aussi si j'ai bien compris
dans cette histoire c'est que c'est
surtout aussi au niveau de
l'alimentation puis d'hydratation qu'on
voulait retirer ses soins parce que
c'est considéré comme dix mois pour
finalement lui permettent d'avoir une
mort plus paisible dans la dignité et il
met fin à certaines souffrances c'est là
qu'une position avec les parents qui
veulent maintenir la vie coûte que coûte
et c'est là que toute la polémique
émergents et parce que leur sa femme qui
demande
l'arrêt des traitements oui les
autrement les demi-frères et ça aussi on
entendu le neveu qui aurait le dernier
mot ici en fait ça dépend toujours de la
condition du patient et si on reprend
puis on calque olic est vrai c'est ça
alors ça serait l'époux ski qui aurait
créé le finalement les consignes à
donner les le consentement aux soins
c'est de cette nature là évidemment les
méthodes les équipes soignantes ont à
faire face dans leur quotidien ils ont
des familles et l' approche consensuelle
c'est vraiment ce qui est mis de l'avant
donc essayer de rallier les gens vers
une décision qui soit partagé commune et
samia de l'accompagnement qui peut se
faire en milieu hospitalier pour
finalement permettre à tout le monde de
cheminer avec la situation puis
d'arriver à une décision qui soit les
hippies accepté de tout ça c'est l'idéal
non vie le portrait de famille là bas
indique un père et une mère très
catholique même très traditionaliste
vraiment d'ailleurs le pape commenter la
chose et de l'autre une femme qui
raconte qu'au fond que sont mes rêves
est rompu avec ce milieu là très catho
qu'il n'aurait jamais voulu ça donc il
aurait exprimé verbalement ses souhaits
de fin de vie et il ne serait pas de
cette manière
respecter parce que si on peut décider
d'arrêter un traitement quand on peut
l'exprimer
oui absolument alors ici bien évidemment
dans un endroit c'est la question
d'attitude de ce qu'on est apte à donner
ou non notre consentement
ils sont comprendre dans la sphère de
monsieur lambert mais il est plus apte
donc c'est pour ça que sa femme serait
la personne toute désignée pour donner
les instructions médical puis également
pour administrer ses biens en nous des
régimes à ce moment là et évidemment
lorsqu'on est mandataire notre fonction
première c'est d'agir dans le meilleur
intérêt de la personne on devient comme
son représentant alors évidemment une
personne qui aurait signalé des
des souhaits quant à des soins de fin de
vie ou une situation comme ça se
produisait quelles étaient ses désirs
bien évidemment ce qui sera mis de
l'avant plus que l'intérêt de labour et
redonner le même que les mandataires
donc c'est toute cette idée là de
substituer finalement et de confier à
une personne parce qu'on nous demande en
cas d'inaptitude
on encourage tout le monde à vivre et
tout ça il semble qu'en france on voit
paraît-il un glissement parce que la
commission internationale des droits des
personnes handicapées s'est prononcé
c'est pour ça que la cour d'appel de
paris veut faire respecter le droit à la
vie de vincent lambert en évoquant le
fait que c'est devenu une personne
handicapée
alors est ce qu on n'introduit pas
quelque chose de bain de niveau de
différents mais probablement je voudrais
que au canada sont veut faire l'analogie
bon évidemment aujourd'hui on ne la loi
sur les soins de fin de vie au québec
qui est un sourire donc on parle pas
d'euthanasie évidemment par mais d'un
soin de son père
oui exactement l'on sait dans un
continuum de soins où les médecins
l'équipe soignante travail avec la
famille le patient est bon pour offrir
les meilleurs soins possibles et ce qui
s'est passé dans le reste du canada
c'est la récolte qui a lui eu quelques
années où finalement on a reconnu l'aide
médicale à mort et les soins de fin de
vie comme étant un droit qui était
reliée à la charte des droits
fondamentaux et on le relier peut-être
certain bruce lee mais c'est en lien
avec le droit à la vie dessus donc le
droit à la vie pour les tribunaux au
canada ça a été interprété également a
le droit d'avoir une mort dans la
dignité et ne pas continuer des saisons
quitterait intolérable au plan humain
que la question ici aussi c'est la
russie entre parce que de vincent
lambert
qu'est-ce que l'acharnement
thérapeutique parce que son doigt le
débrancher arrêter de le nourrir de
l'hydrater là on vous le dira qu'on
donne la fameuse sédation pour soulager
le patient pour ne pas que s'ouvre alors
l'acharnement thérapeutique
effectivement c'est une belle question
qui s'est posée aussi un contexte
québécois puis le collège des médecins
fait des travaux ddd de former des
comités et ce qu'on voit finalement
c'est que l'acharnement thérapeutique
c'est lorsqu'on
une fois les soins appropriés aux
patients donc on serait dans des soins
inappropriés et comment on fait pour
déterminer une fois qu'on a dit ça mais
encore mais c'est à la fois un critère
objectif à savoir que le médecin va
pouvoir nous donner objectivement
quelles seraient les soins requis pour
un patient dans telle circonstance mais
à la fois également ce qui émerge du
côté du patient donc si le patient est
âpre mais qu'est ce qu'il fait ce qu il
veut témoigner quelles sont ces ateliers
son consentement aux soins et dans un
code mandataire mon prêt regarder mais
quels sont les souhaits du monde à terre
puis peut-être élargir un peu aussi à la
famille essayer de chercher un consensus
parce que les médecins savent bien qu'au
delà de ce qui se passe dans l'hôpital
ce sont des vies qui sont impactés de
façon assez majeur donc ont quand même
le souci c'est comme si je crains
parallèle avec le don d'organes on voit
beaucoup cherché le consentement de la
famille un consensus pour finalement
permettre l'apaisement à ces familles là
qui souffrent malades martiaux merci
beaucoup c'est fort éclairant à suivre
bien évidemment merci à vous